for three years the teen comedy Lizzie
McGuire ruled the Disney Channel Roost
with Hilary Duff in the titular role
unfortunately the success of 2003's the
Lizzie McGuire Movie marked the
beginning of the end for the fictional
teen sweetheart that same year
Entertainment Weekly spoke to Susan Duff
Hilary Duff's mother and manager she
said that Disney ended negotiations for
a film sequel when she asked for a
promised bonus to be paid immediately
she also told ew that Disney was trying
to shortchange her daughter to continue
on the Lizzie McGuire series apparently
they offered only 35 thousand dollars
per episode even though they knew she
was being offered six figures by outside
parties in the end it seems that Disney
couldn't give her what she wanted as
both the TV series and the plans for a
movie sequel ended that's okay
I don't want it in 2019 news broke that
a Revival series was being planned for
Disney plus with Duff back and McGuire's
shoes but by the end of 2020 Duff told
fans on her Instagram that the planned
series wouldn't happen